suffering
seriously from the increasingly dire
impacts of climate change
we also have to act
before the hydrological cycle breaks
down altogether
now that we know
what the problem is
and having done our best to test the
world to destruction in the meantime
we simply must talk about the solutions
and the actions we can start making
and start taking today
the first action
i would suggest is to re-engineer
the world's financial economic system to
disincentivize
deforestation
and reward countries and communities
for the protection of their forests
and
the pursuit of a forest positive economy
we will hear from leaders in the
financial sector with ambitious plans to
achieve this goal
after all if we are
to restore the critical balance
between people and planet
we need to protect restore and invest in
nature
investment in natural capital including
fostering
more species-rich systems rather than
sterile monocultures
can support productive
and resilient agriculture forestry
and aquaculture
whilst while avoiding the pitfalls of
climate change
land degradation resource depletion
pollution
and
insect decline
here
the 30 by 30
biodiversity target is truly critical
to support that objective
i helped to establish something called
the natural capital investment alliance
as part of my sustainable markets
initiative
in order
to help develop uh natural capital as an
investment theme
and as a means of mobilizing the world's
financing and investment communities
but i believe
it will be just
you'll be discussing the details behind
the ncia after i
have left here
the second action the world
needs
as a real matter of priority and justice
is to safeguard
and honor the rights of
indigenous
peoples and local communities
who depend on the forest for their lives
and livelihoods
and who are themselves wise
and experienced custodians
in fact i'm wearing what i've been given
earlier when i met them
and this one comes from ecuador
the virtuous circle of nature
is something the world's
indigenous peoples hold sacred
and understand only too well
and is why
we should listen
to and learn from
their profound intuitive wisdom
by contrast we seem to have lost
that vital sixth sense
which should have prevented us from
abusing nature in the first place
today though
we will hear from forest leaders
and donors committed to fulfilling this
promise
we thank those leaders for their bravery
their courage
and their commitment
to protect their forests
and the rich biodiversity that exists
within them despite despite all the
dangers and obstacles placed in their
way
the third important action we need to
take
is the implementation
of an accelerated and serious global
shift in how we produce and consume
goods
decoupling this production and
consumption
from further loss
of forests and other vital ecosystems
and therefore delighted we will be
joined by leaders committed
to shifting to new and more sustainable
practices in this area
there is
every hope
that we can build a more circular
resilient economy
which is better for people
as well as for the forests on which we
all depend
after all nature is estimated to
contribute
some 125 trillion dollars to the global
economy annually
if you can ever actually put a real
value on it
and everything we use produce and
purchase
ultimately has been created from
nature's inputs
in a circular bio economy this this
requires taking a system led view of
global
value chains
the the shift to renewable bio-based
solutions
is therefore an opportunity
to rethink
industries so that they become nature
positive
and climate neutral while providing new
jobs and more inclusive prosperity
all these measures measures would shift
our economy onto a more sustainable
trajectory
and there are now signs that there is at
last growing interest in investing in
these solutions across both public and
private sectors
however if we want to see tangible and
rapid results on the ground
and i'm afraid i do after years of
frustrated effort
then
we need to articulate and demonstrate
the immediate and long-term value of
these investments
this is why i established the circular
bioeconomy alliance
last year to connect the dots between
investors and local communities in order
to create regenerative
and inclusive landscapes and sustainable
value chains that work for nature and
people
frankly
we've all had enough talking so we need
to put our words into commitments into
practice
this is why while i speak
the circular bioeconomy alliance is
working with local communities in four
continents to restore
thousands of hectares in more than ten
countries
to deliver practical solutions
through initially
what we are calling living laboratories
by doing so we will i hope inspire an
entire generation of humanity who will
be equipped to make the changes we so
desperately need
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
and i cannot believe how many times i
have ended speeches like this all over
the world during the past 40 years and
to no avail
but i can only pray that this time
this session will provide us with a real
sense of the seriously urgent systemic
shifts that need to happen to deliver on
our vision
and i
urge you all to take forward the work we
discussed today with implacable resolve
and determination to make things happen
on the ground
thank you
thank you